wow look
well exciting tom cruise lake district
mission impossible no way
trying to deliver for you okay let me
get back on this side
tom delivered all right doing his own mi
stunt work and surprising hiker sunday
in the uk as he paraglided to safety
the actor who was spotted out last night
leaving a play in london's west end has
been shooting mi-7 and 8 back-to-back
production on 7 suffered several coveted
related delays that was difficult on its
own but to have to do our stunts in it
and travel the world i got to see the
world during the time when it was closed
mission impossible dead reckoning part
one is in theaters july of next year
part two june of 2024 tom will turn 62 a
week after its release so what can we
expect from these next two missions it's
great it's epic tom is reportedly making
about 14 million for each mission
impossible movie but he will earn tens
of millions more on the back end
and there's big news with another top
earnings star ellen pompeo who
reportedly makes 20 million dollars a
season on gray's is scaling back her
role on the show trying to reinvent the
show and continually trying to reinvent
the show
is the challenge at this point the
actress will appear in eight episodes of
the upcoming 19th season gray's just hit
a major milestone 400 episodes how's it
feel exhausting
ellen had a bit of a reduced workload
during season 17 while her character was
in a coma but she's played meredith gray
for almost two decades and now ellen
will be tackling a new role starring in
an executive producing an orphan adopted
theme series for hulu but the big
question will this be ellen and gray's
farewell season could you ever see a
world of grey's anatomy going on without
you without meredith we'll see and we're
going to try to keep it going for the
young people not necessarily with me but
you know to keep it going beyond me
whose anatomy would it be
well we'll find someone maybe or or we
won't
[Music]
you